you make sure you get your he might
softly never see your most embarrassing
moments BK's but thanks to the internet
we have found out that you villain kids
aren't always too cool for school you
forget your lines and drop your swords
you goof off and laugh a lot that's
right VK so we have found The
Descendants Three's blooper reel now we
know exactly how clumsy and silly the
coolest kids from the aisle can be we
are almost excited about the gag reel
from descendants three as we are about
the movie itself you won't believe which
cast member nearly got dropped keep
watching for the 10 funniest descendants
three bloopers I can't believe I get to
live with you in your very own yeah it's
just a little starter Castle sword
skills
Disney has teased us with the awesome
sword fighting scene where the UK's take
on a bunch of knights and armor this was
the first scene that was filmed for the
movie and it took months to rehearse
that wasn't enough for dub now gets a
sword tossed at her she is supposed to
catch it but she fumbles it like crazy
we hope those swords weren't sharp it
turns out that mal isn't a fighting
expert that she appears to be in the
movies time to talk it's really common
for actors to forget their lines but it
doesn't make it any less funny when we
see it on the gag reel one of the best
moments happens to Brennan add a Mingo
who plays Jane she looks totally amazing
in the scene with her on-screen
boyfriend Carlos there's a long ties
before she remembers that she has to
talk she just totally forgot her cue
Cameron voice must have been really
confused waiting on her to speak
surprise I love you one of the cutest
couples in descendants is Doug and Evie
they've been together for a while now so
naturally they have really strong
feelings for each other but the way
Sofia delivers her line of I love you is
totally random the two were watching
something off screen Doug says that it
makes their movie night seem tame all of
the sudden Evie turn
sorry it was so random and forceful that
the whole set burst into laughter don't
smile
the dissonance movies have a lot of
serious moments but it can't be easy to
stop smiling when you're having so much
fun on set the Nuvi k's are dizzy celia
and the smee twins we see them looking
out the window of the limo presumably on
their way to Oregon
they look shops but really happy the
director yells for them throats Laurel
and that note had the opposite effect
dizzy starts grinning and the rest start
giggling man down we know that there is
a sleeping spell that has taken over our
Don in the new movie and it appears that
doug is one of the victims we see Evie
in her studio trying to wake him with a
kiss he is lying on her table she is
confused about when to kiss him then he
just launches himself off the table onto
the ground it's so random and sudden
Evie and everyone else just lose it and
so did we think that's hilarious keep
watching for boo-boo Stuart's big
boo-boo bad hair day we are so excited
that audrey is back in the new movie and
she's playing the big bad villain this
time around
Audrey is always so polished but when
she's filming things aren't always
picture-perfect she's posed very
seriously but her hair gets caught on
her hand it ends up all messed up
she looks so annoyed that it happened
work it boo boo the cast was so glad to
reunite and film the third movie they
always have such an amazing time when
they're all together one hilarious
moment happened on the second day of
filming Cameron Boyce and booboo Stewart
are in their VK costumes boo boo is
walking like a supermodel
Cameron is filming them and giving him
runway feedback boo boo even does the
hair clip we laughed so hard these two
are such goofballs wicked dance moves
one of the best parts of The Descendants
movies is the dancing all of the actors
are such talented dancers and they
obviously love to dance even when they
aren't filming the gag will include
several of the cast members doing funny
dance moves chat charming does an old
Broadway style kick Carlos's shimmy and
like crazy which rubbed off on Jane it
looks like the set of descendants three
was just one huge dance party we are
here for it ring
nothing can kill a serious scene like
someone's phone ringing a very important
scene was being filmed
toward the end Ben's parents fell and
Adam are looking all fancy and royal the
director Kenny Ortega yells the ball
whoops but then he says that it is his
bone we hear someone get on to him
jokingly we guess Kenny can't chew
himself out for not silencing his own
phone don't drop him there are some wild
stunts in the new movie in one scene in
particular carlos and jay jump from
somewhere kind of high they're supposed
to land in the arms of backup dancers
carlos falls perfectly and immediately
bounces back up like he is supposed to
but jay didn't quite mash through that
fall he starts falling backwards the
other dancers struggled to keep him from
totally going down then they all nearly
fall together the best part is when
someone yells at boo-boo made a boo-boo
which of these bloopers made you laugh
the hardest let us know in the comments
thanks for watching give us a thumbs up
and hit that big red subscribe button so
you never miss another awesome video
[Music]